zwar werden damen und herren willkommen
zum höhepunkt des programms
okay das fragen lotto ich sehe du hast
was vorbereitet wir haben da mal was
vorbereitet
rote umfang erkennt die grünen sind
harmlos die roten sind gemein so für
jeden eine okay da muss ein abonnenten
eure texte haben zum größten teil keine
message und beinhalten nur proleten
gehabe könnt ihr zusammen nichts
tiefgründige schreiben da haben die das
ist keine frage für mich sondern dass
eine feststellung bzw ein kompliment
also es ist tatsächlich fakt dass wir
dass unsere texte wirklich nur proleten
gabe sind kein message haben
und wenn die message ist oder wenn sie
so tiefgründig ist dann soll diese
message sein erniedrigt rapper und [ __ ]
mütter aber das wichtigste dabei ist
immer mit kondomen und an dieser stelle
schon jemanden grüßen ich habe gestern
eine kette bekommt von meinem freund
mohammed garmashago meine berber kette
hat mir geschenkt dass seine lieblings
geht und hat gesagt ich will dass sie
die tricks ich weiß dass schönen gruß an
machen mit und ohne schon okay die
nächste frage habt ihr ein treffen sich
schon auch von mir schöne grüße und ja
ich habe hier die frage ihr macht euch
häufig über andere lustig wollte damit
von euren eigenen schwächen ablenken was
unsere schwächen angeht
ich hab heute ist die 130 nur zwei mal
gedrückt das schwache leistung
ich habe ja ich habe auch ich hab dann
wiederum beim butterfly habe ich nicht
dass maximal
und es ist es wirklich so hätten wir da
jetzt nicht darüber über diese schwächen
das belastet einen schon klar
der tag war auch wirklich dann
eigentlich schon immer
und was wir zu machen die da jeder seine
schwächen auch männer müssen mal
schwächen zeigen selbst ihr beiden okay
wir wollen von dieser depressiven phasen
und wiederholt schnell beantwortet ihr
beide seid absolute wortspiel talente
wie schafft man es selbst nach so langer
zeit immer noch so kreativ zu sein
ja das geheimrezept lautet immer schön
scrabble spielen mit dem toxic schönen
grundlage ingo lehmann sowie im haupt
interview
die anekdote mit den jungen dame die
mich darauf den balkon gestellt hat man
wird immer wieder inspiriert durch
vorfälle im alltag 50 paare durst so
einen langen penis ist es nicht
unangenehm für dich diesen in eine frau
hineinzustecken
ja es ist natürlich nicht so einfach wie
man denkt es ist schon eine gute sache
und ja also ich muss auch sagen ich
gehöre zu den wenigen menschen die bei
einem metzger beschnitten worden sind
und wirklich die polizei mit einer
auflage gesetzt hat und zwar dass ich
eine schwanz verkürzung weil sonst jeder
also jedem geschlechtsverkehr den ich
habe mit einer frau als körperverletzung
geld und deswegen ich mich jetzt in den
nächsten zwei bis drei wochen operieren
lassen muss und wirklich das ganze auch
bisschen eingeschränkt wird von diesen
37 cm auf 22 das ganze reduziert wird
aber ich denke es wird dann trotzdem
noch der ein oder
und frau spaß bringen bitte zu dass du
vor der tour nach dem arztbesuch am
herzen
in so ziemlich jedem video und song
erzählt ihr wie gut aussehend und
talentiert ihr seid seid ihr nicht etwas
abgehoben
ich glaube da sind andere rapper ti
diesen mehr abgehoben wenn ich mir das
letzte video angucke von mo trip graf
kamera und und wege die so abgehoben
sind dass ich schon auf dem mond
gelandet sind also da gibt es andere
kandidaten die da wesentlich mehr
abgehoben sind
dem sollten sich auch mal einige rapper
ein beispiel nehmen die meisten bürger
kann sie zum mond schießen
die drei haben es jetzt freiwilliger
weise schon zuvorkommender weise schon
vorgemacht spaß ich bin cool mit 1 3 ps
an euch und ja also anfrage
farid du bist bekannt einen besonders
großen und ausgeprägten genitalbereich
wie hast du es geschafft in so kurzer
zeit so große und dicke muskeln
aufzubauen und wie siehst du immer so
gut aus und biss zu stark und wie kommst
du auf diese krassen wortspiele und
stimmt es dass du sex hat es mit einigen
prominenten damen ja die frau beschrieb
den beispiel fragen gemacht wie ich das
mal sitzen schwieriger job habe ich mein
es gibt noch jemand also ich kenne mich
jetzt außer kollegen mir gibt's nur
superman der so einen ähnlichen job hat
also einfach gut ausschauen schön ster
holz immer schön rein kann ja und
anschließend das selbe wie immer ne die
leier wiederholt sich also es ist immer
dasselbe
schön in den arsch [ __ ] warum in den
arsch also der arsch ist heutzutage eine
andere funktion bei einer frau ist ein
verhütungsmittel für den mann aber okay
der arsch einer frau ist ein
verhütungsmittel für den mann
das ist ihr gesagt sein er bei euch kann
man etwas lernen wir auf jeden fall
und da kommen wir dann wieder zu meinem
bekannten sprichwort es macht spaß es
macht laune erste a stand keine ahnung
die rutsche diplom und die letzte frage
lautet ihr erzählt oft davon
insbesondere fahrräder einen sehr
ausgeprägten geschlechts bereich hat wie
auch du mein lieber was er erzählt auch
von geschlechtsverkehr mit verschiedenen
frauen gibt es bei euch dabei kein
konkurrenzkampf übels die bürger
wirklich schon echt schon oft deswegen
gezeigt weil es immer wichtig ist weil
er dann vielleicht millisekunde
schneller drin war als ich und er ist
das ist nicht lustig also wir versuchen
wirklich zeitgleich in die frau
einzudringen so dass sie direkt beim
eindringen in orgasmus hat ihr fragt
euch natürlich wie macht ihr zwei dass
einer in den hintern und der andere ins
fäustchen und so machen wir das
also das heißt die karte kommt den po
und der pille man ihn die freundin die
flamme ok also wir haben wieder war sie
viel wichtige sachen gelernt bei
kollegah und farid bang vielen dank so
gerne
und ja das war wieder eine lehrstunde
nicht unbedingt in rap ja aber ich hoffe
wir haben alle unseren spaß gehabt was
gelernt ich hoffe du merkst du den
spruch mit dem mit pflaume arbeiten aber
trotzdem danke fürs interview wir haben
zu danken und weiterhin viel erfolg und
liebe freunde achter zweiter kauf das
album index zuschlägt